waiting for you to break down but if
this was
[Music]
look what you made her do
you do look what you just made me do
Taylor Swift drops four unreleased songs
in honor of her eras tour I'm so excited
about this tour now we're breaking down
all the Deeds you need to know oh
awesome the midnight singer announced
the news on Instagram Thursday in
celebration of the tour kicking off
Friday in Glendale Arizona she's
releasing eyes open Taylor's version
safe and sound Taylor's version if this
was a movie Taylor's version and the
previously leaked track all of the girls
You Loved Before
[Music]
Taylor originally released eyes open and
safe and sound for the Hunger Game
soundtrack in 2012.
[Music]
if this was a movie was first featured
on the deluxe version of her third album
speak now in 2012 which fans speculate
will be her next album re-recording
[Music]
all the girls You Loved Before is a
track that was considered for Tay's
seventh studio album lover but didn't
make the cut
[Music]
the song was leaked last month and went
viral on Tick Tock prompting fans to beg
for its release I would always like to
keep people on their toes oh and
swifties are fully convinced it's about
her longtime partner Joe Allen all of
the girls
[Music]
more specifically fans theorize that the
track is a sweet note to all Joe's exes
[Music]
but I love you more since Taylor left
record label big machine before she
recorded the song A Taylor's version
wasn't needed for the track of course
Taylor most recently released her 10th
studio album Midnight and announced
she's going on her eras tour which kicks
off on Friday on Monday the mayor of
Glendale Arizona changed the name of the
city to Swift City in honor of her
arrival and we'll change it back after
her back-to-back shows like I don't
understand how you cannot fan girl about
that as for Taylor she gave fans a sneak
peek of her rehearsals on Thursday with
a series of snaps on Instagram alongside
the caption in my eras era
[Music]
thank you